[Music]
how is the Shawn Mendes today that we
see now different from the guy that we
first met I think the main thing for me
is I've grown up and kind of just become
a lot more just cool and happy with
being in my body I'm not as worried
about what people think
wise beyond his 19 years of age Shawn's
post friend Taylor Swift has already
given his new self-titled album a
stellar review and your song is amazing
thank you John Mayer collaborates with
Mendes on the album he told beats 1
radio that Shawn is just like him really
better
Shawn's like John Mayer 2.0 without
really the weird software viruses like I
was a beta version of a celebrity and
he's just a better he's a better version
so everybody that I ever was
I had done mayor to be able to tell me
what not to do he did it so thank you I
mean that that's so cool of him and it's
a crazy thing when your idols become
your friends but that's really cool Sean
is gearing up to go on a tour next year
[Music]
his new video is for the single in my
blood the deeply personal lyrics are
about struggles with anxiety it's about
experience in the feeling and how the
world crashes down around you but over
how you can always overcome that I put
my story out there and I hope people can
kind of connect with it and use it for
them and no doubt helping a lot of
people way to go Sean
[Music]